buenos días muchas gracias por su
invitación
los pueblos indígenas de toda la región
antes de esta pandemia ya padecían los
problemas propios del desamparo estatal
las vías de acceso principalmente son
una de las dificultades más grandes
además de la falta de comprensión y de
traducción a sus idiomas maternos lo
cual dificulta en sí mismo la
posibilidad de que accedan a las vacunas
además de todas las dificultades de
exclusión
y racismo que todavía vivimos
lamentablemente en nuestra región por
esa razón en este momento además de los
otros problemas que se están enfrentando
como la falta de tierras la presión
sobre sus territorios y sobre esos
recursos de además de todo deben
enfrentarse a
y estar en la última parte de la cola
frente al proceso de vacunación en la
región ahora abrió además de esto le
quiero preguntar si hay resistencia en
muchas personas a lo mejor de la tercera
edad que desconfían de la vacuna debido
a su creencia en las medicinas
tradicionales a base de plantas y otras
y también las recomendaciones de los
líderes religiosos
bueno sobre esto puede haber mucho que
discutir seguramente habrán pueblos que
confían mucho en su medicina tradicional
sin embargo lo importante es que estén
disponibles las vacunas que las personas
tengan la capacidad de decidir si la
colocan o no las colocan creo que en
este momento para las comunidades
indígenas
y decidir sobre algo que no está
presente también se convierte en una
discusión
esther ya pienso que lo importante en
este momento es que podamos generar
campañas a nivel continental para que
exista un mecanismo de acceso a los
pueblos indígenas para las vacunas sin
que se convierta en un mecanismo de
presión frente a sus demandas actuales
que también siguen siendo muy
importantes en temas como
las otras enfermedades que también
padecen las comunidades indígenas y que
están siendo muy fuertes en este momento
y de eso les quería preguntar y ahí va
orientaba mi tercera pregunta cómo es la
situación sanitaria actual de las
comunidades indígenas en nuestras
regiones y cuáles son las más afectadas
mira una de las principales afectaciones
es el hambre muchas de nuestras
comunidades como en el norte de colombia
la guajira en el sur o en la amazonía
misma están padeciendo de muchas
enfermedades asociadas a la malnutrición
y a la escasez de agua potable
enfermedades que son ya superadas en el
resto de la humanidad todavía siguen
estando presente en las comunidades
indígenas principalmente en la niñez y
en la tercera edad asociadas a
enfermedades pulmonares a enfermedades
de la piel principalmente darío gracias
por su tiempo y por estar aquí con
nosotros en francia